under the Trump administration members
of the intelligence community have been
endlessly smeared but national security
officials have only been somewhat
smeared and now Donald Trump's own
former national security officials along
with a whole bunch of others have
completely turned on him signing a
letter saying the Ukraine whistleblower
which we now know are actually multiple
as we get a second whistleblower close
to coming forward the Ukraine
whistleblower did nothing wrong and the
Ukraine whistleblower deserves to be
protected and once again we should all
know this and once again more people
fall off of being able to defend the
absolutely indefensible actions of
Donald Trump this letter was signed by
9090 former national security officials
and some of them literally worked for
Trump
like James Nealon Roberta Jacobson and
Andrea Kendall Taylor it otherwise is
signed by a whole bunch of Democrats and
a whole bunch of Republicans now there's
something interesting here there are two
ways to interpret when Republicans and
Democrats agree about something in
politics in the United States because
Democrats and Republicans agreeing does
not happen often and it's not by default
a good thing I'll explain what I mean
very often when Democrats and
Republicans agree on something
it's an element of our political system
that reinforces the status quo so for
example on lots of broad issues
Republicans and Democrats are basically
deferential to the way that things are
campaign finance for example in terms of
actually changing the laws around it the
military industrial complex and funding
of the Pentagon there are exceptions of
course mostly Democrats but those are
areas where you see a lot of deference
from Republicans and Democrats to the
status quo and defending the old guard
so sometimes when you see Democrats and
Republicans agreeing it's not actually a
good sign but this is not that this is
both Democrats and Republicans standing
up to defend the speech of those who
want to hold government
countable they are standing up to
protect someone who is trying to raise
an alarm about what government is doing
so we have to take it very seriously and
Trump has of course completely panicked
over this and spent the morning with
unhinged tweet after tweet including
endlessly smearing the whistleblower who
of course has done nothing wrong
one example tweet of the incoherence and
panicked Trump saying declassified
information contradicts the
whistleblower Fox and Friends but why
are people surprised the partisan
whistleblower was very wrong on what was
said on my perfect no pressure call with
the Ukrainian president bring in another
whistleblower from the bench I'm
actually realizing that Trump's
pathological lying and constant use of
projection makes it easier to figure out
the truth from what he tweets when Trump
says it was a perfect no pressure call
with the Ukrainian president that means
the opposite it was a call specifically
to pressure Ukraine which is exactly
what the whistleblower claims and by the
way Trump got this from Fox and Friends
understand that what Donald Trump has at
his fingertips are the most up-to-date
analyses and data from 17 or more
agencies from intelligence professionals
and instead Trump is gathering
information and building his point of
view from Steve Doocy and Brian Kilmeade
on Fox & Friends
if we don't fix this we deserve what we
get as a result and I don't say that in
any kind of threatening or demeaning
manner it's if this does not if people
aren't paying attention or are so skewed
in how they interpret what is taking
place that this doesn't raise the alarm
to a degree that we can remove this guy
in November of 2020 then in a sense we
deserve what we get because it's
pathetic and it would be a huge
embarrassment which by the way the
embarrassing element I'm gonna deal with
later this week in audience questions
let me know your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinkie's is a great service that i use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is calm slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa k mas